howdy folks it's your boy joe derosa why
am i talking like this because i got a
big announcement to make i am shooting
my new one hour special
that's 60 minutes of new material for me
shooting it at the come and take it
festival in houston texas when real soon
may
19th that's a thursday and again on may
22nd that's a sunday we're doing one
show on thursday one show on sunday
that's it we're banging out this new
hour
i think it's going to be called i never
promised you a rose garden which is a
title that is making me laugh in my
day-to-day life
uh and as you can tell by the working
title it is an hour of uplifting
positive material folks i'm doing what i
do up there on the stage it is going to
be 60 straight minutes of pissing and
moaning bitching and complaining but i
promise you it's funny again one show at
the come and take confess on thursday
the 19th of may a second show on the
22nd which is a sunday in may doing both
very very very and i'm not just saying
this is a as a gag to sell tickets very
limited occupancies these are very small
intimate shows uh honestly i think
there's about 60 to 70 seats available
at for each show and tickets are already
selling so if you want to come out come
out get your ticket quick because
they're going fast it's going to be a
lot of fun and then
if you don't live in houston but you
live in texas maybe out in the austin
area on may 20th and 21st in between
these two shows i will be
doing shows at the creek and cave in
austin texas four shows two shows friday
the 20th two shows again on the 21st so
come check me out if you're in the
austin area and you can't make it over
to houston uh and then finally finally i
will also in june be at fort collins at
the comedy fort that's fort collins
colorado at the comedy fort
and then in july i will be at the punch
line in san francisco go to joe
derosa.info
for information on all the dates i've
mentioned and to buy tickets for any of
these dates
again especially for that one hour
special taping in houston texas uh
that's that's a that's important so
anyway uh they're all important but you
know what i mean anyway i'll see you out
there folks april 23rd and 24th i will
be in tulsa and oklahoma city beacon
theater new york city first time may
14th there's going to be some surprise
guests there and that's all i can say
but you do not want to miss that and i'm
going out west cali i'm finally coming
to you i'm going to be in san diego on
may 21st and at the wiltern theater in
los angeles for the first time ever on
may 22nd everything is available right
now at savolcanocomedy.com you little
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds hey taste buddies welcome to
t-a-s-e-e
buds it is a lightning round episode
today on the taste buds podcast slash
youtube program
whoever wins each round gets a win
towards their record whoever loses each
round gets a loss towards their record i
have been losing like crazy
i am getting buried i think i'm like ten
days just go back to the ditch where you
came from
yeah this is just go back to the ditch
from which you came oh yeah yeah uh we
got three battles today we got ranch
versus blue cheese we got hot sauce
versus barbecue sauce and we have honey
mustard versus sweet and sour
each round will take eight minutes yes
pimp you will time us i think we if we
can get a timer on the screen that would
be great right
uh thank you oh we're fancy now i should
have said that beforehand but i didn't
um we got each round will last eight
minutes uh it'll probably go over
because you don't know how to stop and
you can't control yourself and you keep
talking word word word word oh you you
went with me on that i think i thought i
was gonna get pushed back no i know my
downsides i was gonna get a little push
back
all right good
uh what else that's it right would you
pull up a website from 1985. look at
this this looks like this looks like in
the movies when they have you can't blow
something with some flesh
this looks like
movies from the earth
in the movies from the early 90s when
the internet was doing it they would
have a website you're like
that's not what they look like it's like
the file is deleted what was that awful
movie about the hackers from the 80s
hackers
speakers a little kid who like fought
hackers or something oh there were a lot
there was the web
sneakers when we were little what about
whiz kids remember the show whiz kids
whizz kids
uh
there was a movie called hackers i think
i think you're thinking of a movie that
was literally called hackers i think can
i can i prove a point have you ever said
the phrase i gotta take a whiz
yeah she say it all the time pimp have
you ever said the phrase i gotta take a
whiz never
really never okay my point was gonna be
that you said yes and then i was gonna
say v have you ever said i gotta take a
whiz because i don't think women say i
gotta take a whiz i think it's a male
exclusive thing
yeah you piss i do i gotta take a piss
yeah well that's what it's called though
is it it's piss i thought like it was a
piss off i thought it was like an
english urine
i thought urine pee or piss is like
second to urine which is the textbook
term i thought take a picture a wiz is
definitely
like uh
yeah
yeah
the two grossest ways yeah that'd be
great
most guys like i gotta take a piss
what do you say it would it would it
would take me it would take me out of a
romantic relationship yeah if i heard
that
i wouldn't be able to honestly if you if
you if you sat down at a date on a date
with me and you ordered a hot dog i'd be
like i gotta go take a piss
and walk out take a piss the grossest
way to save her take a squirt or hang a
piss i never heard a hang of hiss yeah
they're guys you say i gotta go hang a
piss
i never
wait now i'm so curious what is the most
nitpicky thing you broke up with a woman
for oh god don't where to where to begin
i got a whole bit i have a whole bit on
it
on about me
no
i i had one girl that kept spelling the
word hysterical wrong and text messages
i couldn't stomach it she would write it
h-y-s-t-e-r-i-c-l-e
and then i did that thing where i was
like oh was it hysterical but i wrote it
correctly when i wrote back and then she
wrote back and she's like yeah it was
historical and she didn't correct it but
then that girl started going jealous
like and i hated that
she's like she would say little stuff
like
oh yeah i i dated a girl that every time
i saw her
she would give me a kiss hello and she'd
go mwah
so that was i broke up with her seinfeld
episodes yeah
i i stopped seeing a girl because she
would go when you were talking or she
would go question
oh
that's what this girl was though she
would go like uh she would say like uh
it's only 9 a.m and i already did yoga
jealous oh god yeah i just parallel
parked on the first try jealous
yeah yeah it's it's it's different
movies where did they learn that i don't
know it was just like a maybe the front
of friends that i don't know one girl uh
anybody that was personal sorry was that
one girl used the word genitals that was
a big turn off anybody that refers to
themselves in third person i can't
that's a real bad one for me actually uh
i had a there's another one in there i
had a girl i borrowed her apartment
and uh she was away and she only had
flax seeds
in the fridge and all the cabinets it
was just flax seeds there was no kind of
she had bag of flax another bag of flax
and then and then i was looking for
other food and a cabinet was another bag
of flax so she just had tons of flax
sounds like you're dating like serial
killers i agree and there was no there
was no other food and she didn't let me
know that there was only flax and then
like when i opened the door to eat that
night there was nothing but flax
i was like it's two now it's too late to
order and the whole night i couldn't eat
because it was nothing but flax
and uh
and and i'm still with that girl
really you know well no i do but what
was your deal with the i don't [ __ ]
know ask her when you see her i will
flax flax flax everything flax i was
like i think she put it in the drinks
that she made with the blender i think
she was i think she was going on
vacation maybe it didn't stock up
all i know is there was only flags
i hold it again this is like a nightmare
all right and by the way
i look this up it's flax seeds you know
it's flax seeds so
so
what does seeds grow and become a flax
now there's only flax seeds you
understand what i'm saying flax seeds
there's nothing there's no flax there's
only flax seed
it's got to come from a plant no it
comes from flaxseed
where do the seeds come from i know as
well stop it i i'm telling you it's an
anomaly they grow in a flower or
something like that's come on stop that
that can't see flax is grown for its
seeds there you go right there is a flax
no it's grown for its seeds
there's a thing called flax that is
grown and the seeds are harvested from
the flax plant do flax seeds grow into
plants common flax
and the seeds should be planted as soon
as they ground because it works looking
yes no they don't grow
planting site when planting flax from
seed
so it's a there's a plant called flax
stuff click that click that pimp click
that
how to grow flax seed
yeah it comes you have to grow flax you
take the seeds no there's no such thing
as flax bro it just said it was a flax
plant
there's no such thing as flax there's
only flaxseed
trust me
i've done i don't i've done it already
[ __ ] bother me
i'm just let's just do the thing let's
just battle please
yeah let's back in battle yeah let's go
you ready yeah you ready yeah yeah okay
you ready yeah i'm ready all right good
good
salty exciting and salty it's time to
get salty here's my impression of you
ready
i have to travel again
i have to go guest host the academy
awards cause my tv show comes out soon
my life is so hard
the president of the oscars asked me to
come to his house on sunday in the
barbados
i don't get a breath
oh god it's so irritating to hear
anymore
oh my god oh my god oh my god this is
the new chant because this is getting me
angry at the top of every episode good
good oh good good ready ready oh it's
your turn yeah yeah yeah it's time to
get salty
nobody likes you
okay
you're the only person i know that every
friend you have also doesn't like you
it's it's insane it's a yin-yang thing
that nobody else can achieve i love them
to death can't stand them isn't that
something else why why it's something
with you but not with us it's a common
denominator and it's you
all says this i'm in therapy
and on a medication rotation over it i
hear you
medication rotation
here we go that should be salsa
windfall's next album name
medication rotation here we go all right
b-a-t-t-l-e buds first up we got
blue cheese versus ranch you're going
blue cheese i'm going ranch i love blue
cheese but you do not like ranch i like
ranch i love blue cheese doesn't matter
i can fight for ranch i know i can okay
well ranch for me is the least best of
all the dips and all the salad dressings
i don't like the consistency i don't
really like the smell i not i'm not
exactly i've mentioned this before when
we talk about the battles i'm unclear
about what ranch is i don't know what's
in ranch i don't know why it's cold
ranch i don't necessarily like the word
ranch for a dip i
kind of used to like it in a dorito but
now i've eaten it so much that i do not
like it in a dorito if you put doritos
in front of me that a cool ranch i will
pass because i've had enough with the
ranch i know that that's not true
because i saw video of you when you were
doing the tour with chris at christmas
time and you were eating from a bag of
ranch doritos there was three d's they
weren't traditional ranch and it's all
we had and i was starving and i never
had three d's so that was the first time
i had some ranch stuff in as long as i
can remember all right fair enough but i
now i made fun of ranch uh last episode
i think it was or two up with the
chicken fingers episode whatever that
was i made fun of rancid i said if you
had a
ranch stain on your shirt you were trash
yeah uh which i stand by i think ranch
is a completely trashy trashy dip
there's something about it that is very
low class to me i don't know what it is
however doesn't mean i don't like the
flavor and it doesn't mean that i think
it is a superior dipping sauce when it
comes to chicken in general i love blue
cheese for the hot wing however when it
comes to chicken nuggets chicken tenders
chicken fingers
or a non-hot sauce hot wing i want ranch
dressing i understand that that seems to
be popular opinion but i will tell you
nothing
blue cheese excites me so much more than
ranch ranch is kind of just watery is
that some [ __ ] in it i don't know just
something about blue cheese especially
with the blue cheese chunks did i think
i'll dip any chicken into that not just
a hot sauce and i also love it on a
beautiful um uh a beautiful web salad uh
uh
yes wedge salad
yes delicious
um i like it in a nice uh in a nice
spinach salad with uh with some maybe
some like walnut and maybe something
like that in it um blue cheese is an
amazing dressing on a salad absolutely i
love it in a cobb salad absolutely okay
but i think it's versatility stops there
i think blue chips it's a dress it's a
full you could buy dressing well so is
ranch i don't i would never eat ranch on
the salad but i will say this blue
cheese is a great salad dressing
and a great dipping sauce for hot wings
ranch
is a whatever salad dressing i wouldn't
do it or sometimes i will you're going
to demolish me sometimes i will
sometimes i will ranch i don't hate it
on a salad but it's not my first choice
but then when it comes to a dipping
sauce i mean forget it dude people are
putting it on their pizza for god's sake
ranch that's so disgusting bro that is
so disgusting i love it on a black and
blue burger
blue cheese yeah i love it on a burger
okay i just think i
every time i have blue cheese it
complements whatever it's going with so
well and i don't have it often and i'm
always delighted by it and i know it's
kind of this weird
fungusy fungusy type of thing i get that
but the flavor for me is so distinct and
unique to itself like i feel like ranch
can also taste possibly like a couple of
other things but blue cheese is an
island of its own well i'll tell you
this i blew cheese outside of the blue
cheese dressing
or or crumbles that you're gonna put
another dressing on top of is revolting
it's revolting you don't put like if you
don't put a crumbles if you don't i like
crumbles but the dressing's got to go on
top of them that's what i'm saying if
you i would never eat crumbles plain oh
yeah i would i wouldn't i think it's i
think it's gross i mean you can see the
mold you can see the mold right i mean
it's upsetting it's upsetting yeah so
it's not bad mold right well i i guess
not right but you know the ranch on
pizza if you're putting ranch on your
pizza i mean there's so i don't know
where to begin with you it's not
supposed to be on pizza it doesn't taste
good i wouldn't even do it if i was
smoking
high
no i'm drunk i personally wouldn't put
it on pizza but some people like it on
pizza and that's their and that's their
move and i get it like whatever i i
guess i don't get it uh i could see
mozzarella stick and ranch i could see
that not with the sauce too just a stick
i could see that i think ranch also by
the way blue cheese when blue cheese is
is
often bad
you can't get here's the difference
ranch you could buy at the store nine
times out of ten it's good i have yet
yet
to find a blue cheese dressing i like
outside of a quality steakhouse every
time i've bought it at the store it's
disgusting it that's that's really cool
oh that is gross that's really good
lester's fixin's ranch dressing soda
see this is what i'm saying that's out
of control that's out of control i will
tell you i think most people do not
hesitate to dip anything into ranch
that's a joke right the pop-tarts
that's got to be a joke right
let's see
oh no hidden valley's pitching it oh
okay that's disgusting thanks oh my i
guess they had a twitter uh they had a
poll
that's disgusting oh god i will tell you
though i i do think that there's not
anything people want to branch into and
i think that you're going to slaughter
me
but i i just i honestly d i honestly
there's not many things i wouldn't dip
into blue cheese but my question is this
have you ever bought a blue cheese
dressing at the supermarket yeah that
you thought was good because i never
have i find that when i buy it outside
of uh or i get it outside of a
restaurant it is
a lot of time it tastes like mayonnaise
that somebody just put blue cheese into
something gross ranch tastes like it's
really gross it's uh do you know what's
in ranch blue cheese is made using
penicillium penicillium
the type of mold that's responsible for
its unique taste smell and appearance
unlike other types of mold penicillium
does not produce toxins and it's safe to
consume the fact that it's so close to
penicillin is so gross dude
it's so pronounced listen to this listen
how much nicer ranch does that
stop ranch from buttermilk with parsley
diamond dill onion and garlic it sounds
like a shot of black pepper that sounds
like a wonderful watermelon sour cream
and mayonnaise and its herbaceousness
comes from parsley thyme and dill
plus a long pull of allium onion and
garlic and a shot of black pepper well
those things all sound nice and separate
folks i want to talk about one of our
newer sponsors here on taste buds
catalina crunch it's a fun name to say
isn't it catalina crunch uh and it
should be a fun name because it's a fun
product it's cereal
and it's awesome cereal it's cereal
for adults i mean kids can eat it but
let's be honest this is cereal for
adults this is cereal for adults that
grow up loving cereal and want to keep
eating cereal but don't want to keep
eating all the sugar and all the junk
that goes into delicious cereal well
here comes catalina crunch to save the
day
because it tastes great and it is zero
sugar it's keto friendly it's low carb
there are tons of great flavors
you can get variety packs you can give a
few flavors to yourself
or you can give yourself a chance to try
all the flavors or however you want or
if you like one flavor get a bunch of
that one whatever you want to do here
it's your fun time all right i got a
routine i wake up in the morning i do
find breakfast important but
uh you know some folks believe breakfast
should be the largest meal of the day i
don't agree with that at all i think
breakfast should be a good succinct and
fulfilling meal but something that
doesn't weigh you down something that
doesn't make you tired obviously you
don't want to go back to bed since you
just woke up and i find that catalina
crunch fits perfectly into that regiment
it's absolutely delicious
you know most zero sugar food doesn't
taste delicious okay let's be honest uh
and it's got a whopping 11 grams of
plant-based protein it's going to give
you some energy for the day it's got 9
grams of fiber that's what you need to
get going
they've got eight crave worthy flavors
to choose from uh you know like
cinnamon toast which is very nostalgic
there's a dark chocolate flavor there's
a chocolate peanut butter flavor that's
my favorite
um
you know
and as i said if you can't choose you
get yourself a variety pack and you're
off to go gluten-free gain free non-gmo
real clean ingredients nothing
artificial what are we waiting for here
go to
buds for 15 off your first order plus
free shipping that's catalina crunch.com
taste buds
again catalinacrunch.com
tastebuds for 15 off your first order
plus free shipping see why catalina
crutch is the fastest growing cereal
brand in america insurance insurance
insurance who likes shopping for
insurance well i'll tell you
not many people by the time you get done
comparing all the companies and the
websites and the numbers and
making the calls
look just cultivating what your options
are is a job in and of itself thank gosh
for policy genius policy genius is a
marketplace where they're going to help
insurance shoppers understand their
options they can compare quotes across
multiple companies and buy a policies
all in one place
this is this is god's work they're doing
if someone relies on you for financial
support whether it's a child an aging
parent maybe even a business partner you
need life insurance life insurance can
give you peace of mind that if something
happens to you
uh you know your loved ones would have a
financial cushion for rent for mortgage
payments for loans for education costs
for everyday expenses whatever it is i
am not in that position however i am
somebody that needs insurance we all
need it but as somebody who is
essentially an independent contractor
running several different businesses you
know i do not have a company or a boss
or whoever telling me here are your
insurance options i'm somebody that's to
go out and find it myself and pay for it
myself and a service like policy genius
makes that a heck of a lot easier for
somebody like me it's a one-stop shop to
find your insurance that you need at the
right place okay at the right price and
now here's what i want you to do just
click the link in the description or
just head to
policygenius.com tastebuds you're going
to answer a few questions and in minutes
you can compare personalized quotes from
top companies and find your lowest price
you could save 50 or more on life
insurance by comparing quotes with
policy
genius
there's a team of licensed experts
policy geniuses if you will at policy
genius who are on hand through the
entire process to help you understand
your options and make decisions with
confidence so come on head over
palestinegenius.com tastebuds get your
free life insurance quotes and see how
much you could save again
policygenius.com
taste buds to get your free life
insurance quotes and see how much you
could save can we where are we at time
was on this battle pimp because i wanted
to go to i want to make sure we get to
comment
all right let's go to comments real
quick before we hit the buzzer
blue cheese on a burger is better than a
ranch on anything hi pimp blue cheese
for when you've got nothing left to lose
i stopped eating buffalo chicken while i
was pregnant because i wasn't allowed to
eat blue cheese and i was not going to
taint the deliciousness of the buffalo
wing with ranch
blue cheese is just moldy cheese
disgusting but it's not though it is
it's not it's good whoever prefers
chunky white stuff
oh i'm gonna get killed on this i know
that uh haters gonna hate but blue
cheese is for those sophisticated
palettes boom boom boom boo cheese is
literally the worst thing ever invented
the only thing i use blue cheese is for
wings and sometimes crumbles on a salad
i i i men i could drink my own weight
and ranch and still not be tired of it
oh that's so disgusting um i might as
well blue wrong
i do think it's b-o-u-e but it doesn't
matter dressing from mold cheese that
smells like dirty feet
if it needs the penicillin to cure
whatever you're catching from it or
all-american dressing so good it's a
dressing dip chip snacks etc okay fair
point why does anyone eat mold
only old people like blue cheese he said
the same thing about fig newtons yeah
blue cheese is for [ __ ] the criminally
insane
that's really funny for some reason
does anybody really know what blue
cheese is i'll pass do you want ranch or
do you want ass breath
all right i think our winner is the
first one we read that was the funniest
one
or the sec first or second one we read
blue cheese yeah for
for when you've got nothing less left to
lose follow sam at it's
sam loop
all right where are we at on time pimp
right there at the wire we should be
right there over thirteen thousand five
hundred votes i'm going to get trounced
here
pimp chase
75
and that should have been uh
a drum roll that would cause we're doing
one by one here right that's all right
yeah are we supposed to look at the end
at the at the no let's do them battle by
battles
derozan ranch is wild ranch ran wild at
75.8 percent for that time blue cheese
at 24.2 which means three out of four
people prefer rancho blue cheese which i
wasn't that surprised at all right
let's go to the next battle the next
battle is
barbecue sauce versus hot sauce this
one's gonna be this one's gonna be crazy
this is but i think barbecue sauce is
more ubiquitous i forget which team you
were i'm hot okay i'm barbecue yeah all
right i'm hot you're not i'm high you're
hot you're not yeah
i mean hit me with it babe because in my
opinion hot sauce has one purpose and
one purpose only again to go on to
chicken
and
when you're dealing with that
this is my opinion i'm giving you you're
nutty right hot sauce let me finish my
taste first
barbecue let me finish my opinion let me
finish my opinion hot sauce has one
purpose to go on to chicken
that's my wife
let me finish my passion with barbecue
sauce let me finish my opinion can i
finish my opinion it's stupid hot sauce
is one purpose
that's to go on to chicken so it's
limited to one food in my opinion and
then on top of that
you're limited to to to to brands i mean
people can all over the place want to go
look babe you tune into hot ones they're
not eating anything with chicken wings
that's it it's a show about chicken
wings buddy no it's a show it's a show
about hot sauce really but it's it's for
buffalo wings it's a hot sauce on wings
but my point is is hot wings you know
hot ones the uh
my point is this you're dealing with one
a one food you're nutty to say that that
hot sauce not many of the sausages are
good that's literally what barbecue
sauce is made for no it's made for
chicken and the ribs and it goes on
burgers and beef ribs but hot sauce you
could put
anything i put hot sauce on a bagel with
uh with with egg and cheese i put hot
sauce in my ramen i put hot sauce in my
arroz con boyo i put hot sauce in almost
nearly everything right i throw some hot
sauce in some soup i throw hot sauce
i've seen hot sauce oh hot sauce on
unscrambled eggs i'll give you um and
chicken people ask chicken wings they
put hot sauce on tables like ketchup and
mustard yes they do
rarely in a mexican restaurant maybe
they do a mexican restaurant hot sauce
it's like what do you want you know
tacos tacos it goes on top of course it
goes on [ __ ] tacos of course it goes
on tacos and burritos and everything in
the mexican i got news for you most your
hot sauce sucks
most of it sucks okay nothing you go to
a restaurant you go you have hot sauce
they'll go like this sure do you want
tabasco sauce do you want chalupa do you
want uh sriracha do you oh they'll have
you go give me the one of that five you
just listed it actually is good chalupa
well those i'm well i'm telling you that
those are like the sort of so played out
but but
uh hot sauce is having a renaissance
there are there are so many hot sauce
skews in supermarkets these days that it
would blow your bees off yeah do you see
the barbecue lineup barbecue has always
been around i'll tell you something i
don't like a tank oh please i don't like
things that attack i'm talking about hot
sauce bob no but not this is not hot
sauce not all hot sauce i add hot sauce
i add hot sauce to a cocktail when i
make my own cocktail sauce how about you
a blind battery how about you a bloody
mary of course how about
any drink a mexican revolution no i
don't even know what that is you're
making things up that don't exist no i'm
not what is a mexican revolution it's a
it's a it's a it's a it's a corona with
a shot of tequila in it and hot sauce
that's disgusting so says you that's a
revolution i i i think that's gross the
uh uh that sounds like a gross drink to
me but listen it doesn't matter sriracha
think about think about sriracha now
it's almost like the oreo
sriracha it is partnering up with every
product you can think of it's rotted
chips sriracha and it stinks no it does
it stinks
sriracha has such a distinct flavor it
it poisons what you added to in my
opinion i think that uh a barbecue
sriracha is like sriracha is like it
just
sriracha's like like a gar like i like
garlic don't get me wrong but sriracha
to me the flavor is like garlic it's
like if you put it in that's what you're
tasting barbecue barbecue is a lot of
sugar so what a lot of i don't like it i
think a barbecue sauce sometimes they'll
be like you want all steak sauce or
barbecue sauce for your uh babe they got
your restaurants i got news for your
burgers they got restaurants
they got restaurants devoted to my sauce
across states in this country do you
i've never seen a hot sauce based
restaurant i've never seen a restaurant
where you go in and and there's six
kinds of hot sauces to match the cuisine
they're doing in that restaurant and
they're putting it on every side of a
barbecue but by the way there's hot
sauce at all barbecue places but if
you're outside of a barbecue place i
think more so you're going to see hot
sauce at a restaurant by demand by
asking than barbecue sauce hot sauce hot
sauce is is spiking right now the market
is on fire as this article says over 54
percent of households have hot sauce in
the pantry
it is becoming a staple condiment you
know what it is now it's ketchup mustard
mayo hot sauce no joke it is the fourth
condiment yes it is that's crazy yes it
is it's just people use barbecue sauce
when they're gonna barbecue
but i don't use it otherwise i really
don't and i don't even love it you go
into a barbecue restaurant that sauce is
meant to go on several yeah if you walk
into a barbecue restaurant you could get
barbecue sauce okay name a hot sauce
restaurant it's in every restaurant no
is there a place called a hot sauce
restaurant where you go and you go oh
the cuisine is no no because barbecue
and we put it on different because
barbecue is speaking to an entire
way of cooking on a barbecue let me tell
you what let me tell you what hot sauce
is right now hot sauce is the new
trendy oh it looks cool to have it on my
shelf
even though most of it sucks and most of
it tastes the same
it's the new tequila it's every
celebrity is going to have their hot
sauce now
restaurant 1868 oh please
okay there's one good congrats you can
go in there get a bloody mary and a
shitty chicken wing covered in tabasco
who cares
you've never even been there who cares
you don't think the barbecue sauce takes
away from a steak
who the [ __ ] is putting on steak people
are talking about people are putting a
barbecue sauce on stuff that's stupid i
don't do that what do you mean on the
grill you don't brush it with barbecue
sauce
no never people do it and i don't like
it those people are dumb and stupid and
shouldn't be doing it i don't know what
to tell you i can't i can't make up for
every stupid person on this podcast
it's not my job they're idiots they
shouldn't be doing that i will tell you
barbecue sauce
barbecue sauce has had its day but hot
sauce is the new kid in town it's the
new kitchen not the new kid on town it's
the trendy kitten that's nice texas
hold'em it's texas hold them when
celebrity poker came out and texas told
them was what they played all of a
sudden oh the only poker game anybody
played was texas holder that's what hot
sauce is it's the thing to be like i
it's it's you know what hot sauce is
texas it's people too dumb to learn how
to drink wine and they want to look like
they know about a food group so they go
look i know i think that that argument
works
nobody i can talk about
you know
on this planet nobody thinks what you
just said makes sense let's talk about
the difference between a pino and a cab
and they go i'm getting a little cloud i
don't know what you're talking about can
we instead talk about tabasco versus
franks
because that's more on my level
that's one of my levels
that i could talk about is amazing
hot sauce is the new give me a no no
maybe maybe the uh small batch artisanal
like oh the scoville unit [ __ ] but you
know you got your frank's your tabasco
your chalupa cholula and your and your
sriracha it's great cholula is my jump
off i put it on all my tacos i mean i
it's like i i can't make it but barbecue
sauce on your tacos no because it's not
meant for tacos okay but you could [ __ ]
you could that's my point is that you
could put hot sauce in anything
anything you could put anything in
anything that's not an argument hot
sauce goes with more stuff than barbecue
sauce i don't think hot sauce goes in
soup like you said i think that's
terrible absolutely i wouldn't like it
god damn it the pots all right just go
to the vote on this one
because we don't have time no i was
about to get heated it was about to get
heated
folks
folks it's lucy time
we're all adults here i know some of us
choose to use nicotine to uh relax and
focus or you know maybe just unwind or
maybe just for fun heck i'm a former
smoker i get it i'm not here to judge
lucy
they're a modern oral nicotine company
that makes nicotine gum lozenges uh and
pouches for adults who are looking for
the best most responsible ways to
consume their nicotine
it's more or less still a new year right
we're i think we're under six months in
wait let's call it a new year why not
start it out by switching to a new
nicotine product that you can feel good
about something that's going to help you
switch
from cigarettes every time you know as i
said i'm a former smoker i stopped a
while back
uh but i do wish that when i was smoking
i would have had access to lucy it came
out right at the tail end of when i was
kind of getting off
but i can tell you this if it was around
for
a larger portion of my tenure i
certainly think i would have smoked less
cigarettes
this is a great means again to switch
from having a cigarette every time you
have that nicotine craze
crave or craze crazes could be used i
think that makes sense uh and and have
something a little uh
just a little better
method for you to be uh ingesting
nicotine versus sucking smoke into your
lungs so if you enjoy using nicotine you
should definitely check out lucy's
products
go to lucy.co.comco
lucy.co that's lucy.co
use the promo code tastebuds at checkout
okay
do it also i got to read this disclaimer
this product contains nicotine nicotine
is an addictive chemical again warning
this product contains nicotine nicotine
is an addictive chemical
but if you're interested in a better way
to use it
visit lucy.co and be sure to use the
promo code tastebuds
joe derosa here from the tastebuds pod
and i've got my morning coffee and i do
mean morning folks it is 8 25 on easter
sunday i am here
doing an ad why
because i'm awake enough to do it
because of trade
coffee
see what i did there
our newest sponsor to the show trade
coffee welcome folks i love coffee as
you can see i love it in the morning i
love it in the day i love it at night i
drink it before bed sometimes because it
doesn't keep me awake because i'm a
lunatic apparently
but anyway
trade coffee is doing something really
cool you go to their site and you do a
quiz
really cool little quiz where you answer
some questions about what you like in
coffee
and then they tell you what kind of
coffee they've got that you
would gel best with it's i love it i
love it it's such a cool thing um
they've got all kinds of flavors i i
tend to sometimes be a french roast man
myself but i really enjoyed all the
flavors the only one i didn't mess with
was the cold brew because i'm not a
psycho
people drinking cold brew my god
almighty how much of a boost do you need
but if you like it they got it uh
so go get it
it's really really great uh and i have
to say that in answering the questions
uh i did get coffee that
suited my
taste buds if you will
folks
it was a good experience it was a
fulfilling experience most importantly
it was a delicious experience uh this is
expert tasted coffee trade coffee uh the
team over there they actually taste test
thousands of coffees to keep 450
different kinds live and ready to ship
every day there's no one perfect coffee
but there's a perfect coffee for you
and trade's human-powered algorithm will
find it
trades first match guarantee is this
they're so confident they'll match you
right the first time that if they don't
they'll take your feedback
and action and an actual coffee expert
will work with you to send you a brand
new bag
for free
i mean you can't beat that all right you
don't like what you get they got a
person's gonna actually work with you
and you're gonna get a new bag for free
but
they don't even think it's gonna go that
far and i don't think it will either go
take the quiz give it a shot you'll see
what i mean
right now trade is offering new
subscribers a total of thirty dollars
off the first order plus free shipping
can't beat that
all you gotta do go to drinktrade.com
tastebuds that's drinktrade.com
tastebuds
there's more than 40 cups of coffee to
get here for free
come on guys do it get started by taking
the quiz at
drinktrade.com taste buds and let trade
find you a coffee you'll love again 40
cups of coffee for free that's drink
trade dot com slash taste buds for
thirty dollars off plus free shipping
because we don't have time no i was
about to get heated it was about to get
heated forgot no pun i forgot
11 000 votes on hot sauce let's see what
we got here just take it
humble pie pips choosing bbq
oh two wins from derose he's coming back
you [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh that is that is that is a rematch
territory it is barbecue sauce after 11
500 votes takes it 53.6
to hot sauce 46.4 and i gotta be honest
i put these up and they're 24-hour polls
and i feel like in 24 hours if i
revisited this you might not have it i
just feel like a hassle is just to get
to get a little momentum because
barbecue sauce is
is here so just the fact that hot sauce
it was it was close i think that you uh
you you are you're in for it all right
all right fine now we got a problem with
this third data [ __ ] man we got a
problem with this third battle yeah we
both like honey mustard and we never
discussed who was gonna take sweet and
sour we just said it was worthy of the
battle itself i could do either one
really yeah i'll take sweet and sour all
right i got honey mustard i'm gonna lose
i just realized i was gonna lose
[ __ ] here we go i can't take three
losses in one sweet and sour are you
nuts you put them in against honeybutts
what are you what are you stupid today
you know what what's going on
i'm over it honey i remember the first
time i ever saw honey mustard i was on a
date i was in i was uh just out of
college
and i was on a date
and someone ordered a grilled chicken
sandwich with a side of honey mustard i
was on a date with and i was like honey
mustard and money mustard might have
been around for a long time i don't know
but the first time i was like what's and
then all of a sudden honey mustard it's
like it got a pr company and it was and
it took off babe i got one honey i got
one word for you honey buster was around
in 42 a.d
holy god no mustard okay i got news i
got i got i got one i got three words
for you three words for you french's
honey mustard that's it game over you
got you have the you have the stones
hot dogs sriracha and then you come at
me in the next sentence babe french i'm
saying to you honey you worked on the
condiment isles you know what i'm not
seeing french is sweet and sour all
right now i might find a bottle of sweet
and sour over in the international food
zone yeah you will bless their hearts in
international foods they're trying their
best no but they're not there's no duck
sauce they're not in the whole
supermarket and we all know it's also
duck sauce right and there's a big sweet
sour duck sauce is different it's very
similar they're similar but there's two
different things
good sweet and sour sauce is usually
associated with authentic chinese
combination of rice vinegar and sugar
probable origin the sweet and sour
mixture is the chinese province of hunan
oh great where kovid came from it's not
oh it knows wuhan
i messed it up sorry sorry
no offense anybody don't palace don't
cancel me
listen i love chinese food i love the
international foods aisle i love sweet
and sour sauce i dip my chicken nuggets
in sweet and sour sauce who would i
thought you would bring up honey mustard
dude it's on you got pretzel flavors
with honey much schneider's honey
mustard pretzel bites this is you you're
going against a titan
but i've never seen honey mustard with
chinese i only i've only ever seen sweet
sour duck sauce hot mustard yeah i get
how much hot mustard i mix it with the
sweetness with our duck sauce oh you do
call it duck sauce no it's called duck
sauce it's that's not sweet and sour
it's similar sweet sour tends to be a
much deeper red see how that red that is
sweet and sour and duck sauce the same
thing all right
google that pimp i mean if it is then
god bless but i'm telling you sweet sour
sauce to me tastes much different than
duck sauce duck sauce doesn't taste sour
at all to me
uh
it's similar to sweet and sour sauce but
slightly fruitier yes i agree with that
in other words when you get sweet and
sour pork sweet and sour chicken if you
get that same
at that at that same chinese restaurant
right you get an egg roll with duck
sauce the duck sauce is looking like
that and the sweet and sour you know is
red it's got a much yeah okay okay it's
got a much punchier in my head those two
are the same thing but they're not but
in my head they are
okay in my head
apples and oranges are the same in my
head i was arguing for duck sauce
but no you weren't you were here for
sweet sour you said the words that's a
dipping sauce at mcdonald's i thought
they were you thought mcdonald's said
duck sauce they were giving out no i
just thought that the asian restaurants
call sweet and sour sauce
why do i do what you know that they
don't sal i swear to god i don't tell
you the truth i thought that they just
called it duck sauce but it's
essentially sweetened sauce you argued
for egg rolls on this very show and i
put duck sauce on them which i don't
with sweet and sour sauce
why why why why can't you believe
something when i'm telling you because
because you're making an excuse cause
you're gonna lose
you're making no i'm going to lose
excuse me like almost like i thought
they were the same thing
i didn't know any better i didn't ask
for anything because i thought they were
the same thing so why do you think i'm
making an excuse it would be an excuse
if i said oh i this isn't fair oh i
thought this could you just say things
you just say things you are the king of
just saying things if there was a
[ __ ] mystery here's the deflection
he can't say
you're right i'm wrong let me see
who am i who am i nobody in the world
haven't said it in weeks
i haven't said it in weeks months i
haven't said it in months on this show
blends of flavor mcdonald's sweet sour
blends apricot and peach flavors
is that what you think is is duck sauce
i
[Music]
i really do i googled what sweet and
sour sauce really is and it just says a
combination of sweet and sour there's no
set ingredients that's what it seems
that's why it's such a dice roll all the
time when you get it because i i tell
you i've bought sweet and sour at times
in a bottled supermarket sometimes i go
oh my god that's amazing other times i
go i take one taste i throw it directly
into the tragic
edible let's go back to your beloved
mcdonald's honey mustard you know what
you get
most of the time when i get a mcnugget
the number one sauce i choose without
fail is sweetness that's insane honey
mustard that's it's like they didn't
even have honey mustard to begin with
they do
they have it now but first of all the
number one dipping sauce for a
mcdonald's chicken nug nugget is
barbecue no it's not followed by hot
mustard no hot mustard google it google
it pimp what are the the most
popular honey then mcnugget sauces
oh
you stupid [ __ ] i don't believe that
yeah oh why because it's wrong because
it's the first thing because as soon as
it doesn't show up
you don't believe me go back to that go
back to the website that that was just
on go back to that why don't i beli i'm
sorry that i don't believe the
statistics brought in by
totalfratmove.com
all right
that's why i don't believe it let show
me two or three that say that it's the
first one that came up it's the first
thing came up when you google it well i
i can't imagine a lot of people are
googling this okay okay let's see what
this one is mashed okay let's see
no one can agree on what the best
dipping sauce is
well there the next one down sweet and
sour honey mustard chili this is just a
little this is all new
they never had that [ __ ]
mcdonald's secret wait wait wait
donald's are secret dipping sauces now
did you know that no no anybody know
where you're going in a few minutes
dipping sauce is ranked through a list
okay signature sauce no idea what that
is i never had that
six
rash
well there's blue cheese isn't even an
option
[ __ ] tangy barbecue that's new and i
know five it's that's what they call
barbecue now sweet and sour four
hot mustard three
spicy buffalo get the [ __ ] out of here
honey mustard number one
number one this article suits you so now
you want to scream my face the article
that came up first after a google search
didn't suit you and it said sweet and
sour all right let's go to the phones we
got 50 45 seconds left
we're eleven can i just say one thing
i didn't believe this but you wouldn't
believe you wouldn't believe how bad
honey mustard is for you
i don't know
but it's bad i don't care it's bad you
can't eat it a lot of it all right oh
because sweet and sour is healthy i'm
sure
i'm sure that's got a real low sugar i'm
just saying i was shocked the dressing
is like lollipops i'm sure that's really
shocked the picture that's really
shocked the day that honey mustard
nutrient facts came across my desk
keep the sweet and sour with the happy
meals this is hardware for sure but i
got to go honey mustard honey mustard is
the elite dipping sauce for all foods
honey mustard is the best condiment of
choice especially our chicken fingers
that's tough because what are you having
with it i go honey mustard because it
goes with more stuff thank you sweet and
sour sauce can kiss my sweet sour ass
come on that was funny give it give it
up it's funny
[Laughter]
sweet and sour because it reminds me of
joe derosa comedy
uh honestly i like honey mustard because
jodorowski comedy hyped it up so much in
the earlier ep it's so good on
everything
how drunk are you fellas right now
shocked that mr honey your chicken
nuggets didn't back his favorite
hey you don't know what i backed yet
all right tried to make my own honey
mustard once [ __ ] yellow mustard sweet
and sour sauce all the way thank you god
no but the [ __ ] yellow mustard isn't the
argument if you like honey mustard
archer you haven't had blood work taken
in quite a while that's very funny all
right let's give the win to joe schmoe
follow him at j.o scope
[Music]
on twitter and let's go for the final
round of the day well what time we have
babe
we're at eight
nine minutes 40. yeah all right we get
it's a tight one the lightning round
today yeah okay all right ready all
right well here's the thing i'm down 2-0
in this uh 0-2 in this lightning round
we're up to another one with 11 000 plus
votes uh there's no data this might be
90 to like ten percent well we'll see i
won't and and and and this is rough
because i put together a string of wins
in the past and all it takes is one
lightning round
to even everything up this was bad and i
still stand by my my dips good hot sauce
blue cheese and sweet and sour great
those are my shame nobody else does
drumroll
not as bad as i thought 60.1 to 39.9
honey mustard takes it that is three
wins for the kid today on the lightning
round episode i still love you babe i
love you though see how i did that so i
just did it and ended yeah that's how
you do it yeah
[Laughter]
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm